Now I'm going to get the brilliant blue of sun rising in the east, right blue band, underneath all this haze layer.
I can see the haze layer, and the right band of light demarcation coming underneath it.
Quite distinctive.
There's a paint.
Good.
There's where there are clouds, apparently.
I drew a white face seven, ready to get left clear.
I doubt you understand.
I drew a small and forward 180 degree approaching sun rise over.
Roger.
He's small in this particle, he's dripped away from you, small in and forward.
It's light, they appear brilliant white.
I doubt he's all in them.
They appear to move on out.
They're very round back towards the flight path.
Come here, I don't think.
Roger, you haven't seen the beacon at this time.
Negative, I still haven't seen the beacon.
Sure.
There was considerable noise, though, there's something where departing.
Again, sir, look.
There was considerable noise of the little doors.
It sounded like those doors blowing open, so I assumed the beacon had departed.
Roger, understand.
Hey, I'm looking for a bit on the ground.
All right, there.
I'm going to take you to the front of the TV control switch to off.
Roger, TV control is off.
Okay.
We have a swipe, a decrease in the pool length.
I'm a DC crash, but I'll do this a little bit.
All right, you're DC current.
Roger, main bus is 24.
All right, let it 28.5.
Roger.
All right.
Hey, good.
Our goal is large.
Did you want to hang me?
Yeah, get him.
Not yet.
I'm planning to do shortly here, though.
All right, your information system-wise computation runs zero at a while.
It gives you eight eight.
All right, eight manual, which is somewhat better than you're indicating on board.
All right, you're on board.
I'm indicating nine six and one zero two.
Oh, boy, what a beautiful shot of Florida.
Roger, let's put them here once in a while, too.
All right, you know, the whole state is clear.
I can see just about off.
There's been a beautiful view coming over Florida.
All right.
One eight zero, y'all.
I got here on manual before it's not controlled.
I'm at the last day life going in the dark.
I've been looking for the lightning beacon.
Five, oh, five, one, eight.
Now, two eight.
I'm sorry, not one eight.
It's light inside.
It is below me.
It's quite a brownish.
It's reddish brown.
And it's set up allowed to do it above the ground.
It's kind of like firing a pitch down thruster.
I get a shower of these little fireflies.
It is flashing now.
It is all right.
It's quite bright.
Quite discernible.
Can't one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, right.
Here's to be about 10 to 12 miles away.
I'm keeping it directly in the window.
At the order of a second magnitude star now.